now here in this room what we wanted to
do
was give you an idea of how to execute
a mid-century modern and i'm going to go
with home office because
it's 2021. i actually started with the
chair
that was my inspiration work from the
chair
i love this pop of color this red chair
is from overstock.com and i love
the shape and let's get honest for a
second about
a desk chair it must be
comfortable but this is really great on
your arms as well as a back
you can sit in it honestly for hours
like we're stuck
doing and then don't forget to get up
out of it and stretch every once in a
while
so for me this was my beginning focal
point and then i built around from there
i love this lamp i found it at home
depot
this art i think is really true of a
mid-century style which is to break up a
single piece of art into two pieces and
separate it
it's very innovative it's got this cool
edgy
black sort of painterly swatches and
swipes in the middle connecting it and i
found those at creighton barrel
speaking of crate and barrel i also
found
this globe i am a big globe collector
i actually probably have about 50 globes
at my house
there's something that not only i love
decoratively
but in this modern age i love to tell my
children
when we used to travel where we're going
on the globe
it's educational and it's soulful now
this rug i love it's from ikea
and the circular pattern in it to me
harkens back
definitely to mid-century so
a lot of ways that you can execute
a very pointed design style is available
on modern websites
everywhere it's just about having
references
building a mood board and then building
it thoughtfully piece by piece
maybe don't go to one vendor for
everything that also is really helpful
in design no matter what you're doing
when it comes to design you want to
remember the journey of
how and where you found that and that
will as marie kondo says
spark joy and vffs we wanted to help you
add some mid-century style to your homes
so each of you are getting a hundred
dollar gift card from costa farms
so that you can go buy a plant
like we have here because there's one
thing
i will say about bringing the outside in
i don't care what decade or time period
you're in
that is really timeless to have nature
in your space
[Music]